In this unit I'm going to teach about colors and materials. The application uses
the GPU to compute a color for each pixel and displays it on the screen. We'll
examine how this color is defined and what limitations there are in displaying
them. In the second half of this unit, we'll show how to create and control
different types of materials. We won't go quite as far as this demo does in it's
selection of materials. It has some interesting styles that we'll discuss more
in the unit about shader programming. However, by the end of this unit, you'll
have a fair sense of how these images are formed. You should have a good start
on color theory and how materials are used. To get a flavor for the sorts of
materials you can apply to a surface give this demo a try now. You'll see the
link in the additional course materials.